bonjour riadh sidaoui merci de répondre
à nos questions sur arte france abdellah
mais de l'abeille bas et donc chargé de
préparer le scrutin national de décembre
prochain
quels obstacles devant lui le gène à à
l'ouest du pays la nl de rallye faf tard
de l'autre
sans oublier les milices les mercenaires
étrangers environ 20000 mission
compliquée non le premier obstacle à mon
avis si la légitimité
nous savons bien qu'il ya eu 75 délégué
à genève dans 73 ont participé et
monsieur habib ben hiba gagné par on ne
touche pas un sou loi alors la grande
question d'ordre structurel et a élu les
soixante quinze délégués qui sont
présents à genève il a eu qui ne pas
appeler bien évidemment non donc il ya
un grand problème d'ordre structurel
à mon avis ce qui s'est passé à jeun
réussir pour cette question doit être
résolue par le consensus
je répète un consensus s'est elle
autorise aussi aux politiques
ça veut dire pas des listes et des
élections entre 75 délégués que nous ne
savons pas qui les a nommés il ya des il
y aura un scrutin national en décembre
prochain mais vous parlez de légitimité
justement comment est-ce que abdelhamid
big ben à petit le prouver sa légitimité
sur le terrain et s'imposer face à la
communauté internationale
son prédécesseur fayçal sa rage arrivé
au pouvoir grâce à un produit processus
onusien en 2015 n'a jamais obtenu la
confiance des deux parlements on
rappelle qu' à tobrouk inquiets qui est
soutenu par que tobrouk soutien
le maréchal rally fighter par exemple
est-ce que abdelhamid l'egba peut
obtenir cette légitimité
voilà encore un autre tacle sur le
terrain c'est son rival annoncer ces
élections monsieur à ghilas hull qui les
aident par le mort de tobrouk est calqué
se prépare le match entre les pattes et
l'armée libyenne a perdu cette élection
donc déjà ce qu'ils ont dû tuer le
terrain et les tribus de l'ouest et
l'armée nationale ils ne seront pas
contents de monsieur david habib
c'est pour cela je dis c'est que c'est
passé à genève toutes les peaux talmont
français doit être un consensus pas des
élections pour 75 délégué un consensus
ça veut dire voilà on va on va choisir
telle ou telle personne pour une phase
transitoire mais le terrain libyen
traître complexe partie cycle soeur qui
deviennent le terrain libyen
ce sont les milices armées et l'armée
nationale et bien dans l'est
donc monsieur de biba qu'est ce qu'il va
faire certes et soutenu par la
communauté internationale par l'onu mais
le terrain les tribus les forces sur le
terrain à mon avis et ecep au pouvoir de
monsieur habib
comment va agir maintenant le maréchal
rallye faf tard le l'homme fort de l'est
du pays
de l'armée nationale libyenne nous
attendons sa réaction lui évidemment il
soutient et l'a soutenu à glace à
laquelle par dix ces élections à genève
donc c'est normalement n'est pas costaud
mais on va voir sa position en plus et
c'est allé un cran aussi de mobiliser
ses troupes
à syrte la même chose pour les forces et
les ministres de l'ouest
nous avons bien aussi que c'est là pour
la première fois officiellement on parle
de trois régions historiques en libye la
cyrénaïque de la laisse la tripolitaine
à l'ouest et faisaient nos sud ce sont
les régions autonomes le faisait n'a été
dirigée par une occupation française
l'internât hic par les anglais la
tripolitaine par les américains avant
1950 et 1953 il y avait
il ya eu l'unification du pays de la
libye aujourd'hui on parle de ces
régions quand on voit la carte militaire
c'est vrai la libye est partagée en
trois ans trois régions autonomes et âme
et donc la question libyenne est très
très très structurelles je veux dire on
parle pas en libye de crise politique
comme on parle en tunisie
je viens de regarder votre reportage
mais on parle du christ d'état d'une
crise d'ordre structurel
ça veut dire l'état n'a pas le monopole
de la violence légitime
autrement dit il n'ya pas une seule
armée nationale homogène
il n'y a pas un seul police nationale et
moselle alors qu'il a construit qui m'a
tuer cette armée nationale où cette
police nationale
la tâche est ardue je pense pas au
miracle le nom de la libye france encore
dans le chaos dans la partition qui est
un fait accompli et ce n'est pas à l'onu
ce n'est pas genève ne sont pas les
grandes villes occidentales qui vont
résoudre un problème d'ordre structurel
en libye en plus et société tribale très
complexe a rien dit des wii vous des
pailles de l'onu de villes occidentales
on a parlé du maréchal afta on attend sa
réaction
mais justement on attend quand même les
réactions à l'international
elle vous quelles seront ses réactions à
l'international justement d'après vous à
mon avis officiellement tout le monde va
soutenir que ce soit la turquie qui est
intervenue en libye que soient les
humeurs à la russie les américains les
anglais les français tout le monde vont
applaudir ce gouvernement le provisoire
est légitime entre de guillemets mais
évidemment aussi toutes ces puissances
vont continuer à soutenir leurs alliés
neuer devant continuer à soutenir les
frères musulmans les islamistes de
tripoli les imams à va continuer ou
l'egypte va continuer à soutenir arriva
à l'est ainsi de suite donc c'est pas
genève qui va résoudre un problème très
complexe au plo tribal je parle en libye
et en plus au plan international puisque
les intérêts des puissances
internationales et régionales en libye
sont nos sources en déterrant tu es et
contradictoires merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions riadh sidaoui je rappelle
que vous êtes expert du monde arabe les
directeurs du car absent